I know I know this is the joke that got
Singaporean comedian Jocelyn Cher a lot
of criticism as well as publicity my
airplanes cannot fly
a reference to Malaysia Airlines flight
370 that went missing in 2014 with 239
people on board
she gained attention around the world
after Malaysian police began
investigating her for incitement and
said they would seek interpol's
assistance to find her
many Malaysians didn't find Charles joke
funny but were confused by the reaction
of the police can't understand the
police action because insult is not
actually a crime
and I think it's not within the
jurisdiction of the state
to really negotiate issues of insult she
asked the latest comedian to get into
trouble with authorities in Asia last
month a court in Vietnam sentenced a
noodle seller to five years in prison
for making a video that allegedly mocked
a senior government official and Sri
Lankan police recently arrested stand-up
comedian Natasha edry Surya for
allegedly insulting Buddhism
I think State responses always
correspond to the confidence of the
state at that particular time I think
nation states everywhere are becoming
increasingly innovated and so there's a
need somehow to respond uh in ways that
uh for one of a better word quite
authoritarian
comedians often use comedy to express
critiques or as an outlet to address
social issues U.S comedian John Stewart
once said when authoritarian governments
are under threat comedians are the first
to get sent away
is a stand-up comedian who spent years
honing his craft he says comedians
should be sensitive and find a balance
people in comedy how you can make fun of
a subject without offending people
having performed in several countries he
says understanding cultural and
political nuances is part of the job
each country has their own sensitivity
and we are all there navigating where is
the funny part
but yet funny
but authorities insistence on policing
comedy is making it more challenging for
comedians to navigate this space
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur